hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcasting
ah
i'm just checking in on you i'm just
checking out how the holiday season is
[ __ ] going for
you did you get some toys for
[ __ ] girls and boys that sounded
really creepy
um hey what's going on i uh been running
around all day podcast is a little bit
late
i was actually doing joe rogan's monster
podcast um
and uh we had a great time talked a
little bit about flying in the
helicopter earlier this week
and uh and then he got me all sold on
buying a [ __ ] sauna
you know joe joe joe [ __ ] tells you
something you're like all right this guy
you know he probably read up on it
whatever
he was like people who do this four
times a [ __ ] week you know
live a long time or some [ __ ] and i'm
just thinking like well i'm an old dad
oh great i should get off of that yeah i
don't care
i'm an old dad
don't make me come on you're too far
away
it's gonna be me in five years oh yeah
you care
you oh
don't do it again
[Laughter]
um so i have to uh make sure i take care
of myself
so uh billy's got some growing up to do
all right been abusing alcohol for a
while now i take the bottle out i slap
it around and let him know who's boss
um i gotta [ __ ] grow up
you mean you need to grow up you need to
take a little bit of response to philly
they [ __ ] say that all the time you
know what you need you need a little bit
of responsibility
uh i've never in my life
understood that expression you need a
little bit of responsibility
they'll pick like the most immature
[ __ ] person ever and tell them you
need some responsibility
and you're like this [ __ ] guy no this
guy does not need to be in charge of
anything
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] because they have
that whole idea oh
well once you have a kid and then you
have you know you're gonna have to
you know change your ways yeah unless
you're a [ __ ] idiot
everything this person is doing is
demonstrating that they're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and you're telling them to go out there
and procreate with somebody
you know what you need is no
responsibility you need a [ __ ]
playpen is what you need there
bucko my new year's resolution is i'm
gonna um
i'm gonna fix i'm gonna fix this little
phone uh headphone jack
i literally sit here with my thumb on
the button like a terrorist you know
what i mean like i lift it off it
you know i'm on my way to [ __ ] having
70 broads in my life
i know that's a hacky joke but the more
you're married to just you're just like
oh god
um anyways
um oh bibo oh bill burr
is [ __ ] slowing down man in a good
way
you know i'm off the sauce who knows for
how long but i'm off the [ __ ] sauce
and i'm actually reading a book i swear
to god
i mean granted it's a sports book does
that even count it's about
uh bob cousy and bill russell's
relationship when i did the herd
somebody over there gave it to me i
believe that's where i got it
and you know one of the things that
always bothered me
you know something i always got meant to
get around to was to know all the
celtics retired numbers
and now that i've read the book i
finally i think i have him down i swear
to god i'm not looking at anything
all right number one is walter brown
he was the original owner of the celtics
number two is red aurabac
the great coach they consider him number
two he got number two because
he's the second most important person in
the celtics history i guess because
number one
is the original owner then it's dennis
johnson number three bill russell number
six
why do i why do i need to know this jojo
white one of the great basketball names
number 10.
and then it's bob kuzie at 14. tommy
heintzen is 15.
some guys tom sanders is
16. 17 is havoc
steals them ball 18's dave cowans
19 is [ __ ] don nelson
21 is bill sharman
22 is ed mccauley
23s frank ramsey 24 sam jones
25 casey jones all right now it's 90 now
it's easy
31. cedric gordon brad maxwell 32's
mchale 33's bird 35's reggie lewis
double zero is [ __ ] robert parish
then there's another guy who just says
his name because he also wore the number
at 18 and didn't want to retire it and
dave collins got it so i don't know his
[ __ ] name so that's not bad
that's not bad um so now i know that and
what does that get me
next time i get into an argument with my
wife number one's walter brown number
two's rhetoric can you do this
[Music]
i'm an old dad i said get off of that
now i need a nap um
anyway so after i did joe's podcast he's
like
he's got like that flotation salt tank
thing in there
and i'm like dude i don't know if like
if i went in that [ __ ] thing for like
an hour
like i always wondered what those things
were like those isolation tanks i mean
that looks [ __ ]
wild they just closed that door and
you're in there floating and pitch black
like you're floating through space like
sandra bullock in that movie
right with the other guy there was never
going to get married and then he did
george clooney right he just sort of
floated off into space i could never get
my [ __ ] together you go back to the
[ __ ]
spacecraft i'm just gonna float away
that movie i feel like you'd feel like
that
you know if i ever get a role i get to
play an astronaut
that's that's going to be how i'm going
to prepare for the role bill what did
you do to prepare
for a role to play an astronaut well i
kept my boston accent and i just went to
an isolation tank
and just laid there in a bathing suit do
you think it helped you
no but it gave me something to say in
this interview
um anyway so he had a sauna there which
i'm totally sold on now we went there
we tried to be in there for like a
[ __ ] half hour he could do it i could
i
made like there was eight minutes left
10 minutes left i made 20 minutes it was
like 200 [ __ ] degrees in there
that's what he was saying like how the
[ __ ] is it 200 degrees now doesn't water
boil
at like 212 degrees or some [ __ ]
100 degrees celsius um
i guess those saunas can get hotter
because it's not like because it's a dry
heat i have no idea on all i know i was
just like
all right 10 minutes left he goes come
on tough it out i'm like all right
and then ten minutes later i'm like how
much time's left and he's like eight
minutes i'm like [ __ ]
and it at like five minutes i laid down
and he's like all right dude he knew i
was too stubborn so he [ __ ] opened
the door and then i was fine he goes you
almost made it
it's like i think i did all right i
don't think i need to go any further
than that but uh
i felt [ __ ] great i felt peaceful i
felt calm
i didn't feel like yelling at anybody or
walking around being a [ __ ] emotional
lunatic that just wears people out
um so whatever
i'll see they makes little two-person
ones i wonder if i could fit in my
[ __ ] little ass garage
you know that would be great
you know anytime you have a disagreement
with your spouse right
you just go into the sauna the rule is
you go in there for a half hour
and then when you come out then you talk
about it
hey man like you left your shoes in the
hall man
oh i'm sorry man it's okay it's not
doesn't really
i don't know why it bothered me 31
minutes ago but
it did but that's you know what you can
put your shoes wherever you want
ah thank you i appreciate that
[Laughter]
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about so anyways
um i got not only do i have all my
christmas shopping done i got them i got
it all wrapped
except for one i bought my my daughter
this book uh
the i had a grinch stole christmas i
bought that on the road and i just
i forgot i had it i tucked it away in
the drawer because i know if she saw it
she'd be like book book
read read um
so i'm gonna i just have to wrap that
and then i think i'm done
i think i'm done and i think for once my
super smart wife hasn't figured out what
anything that i'm gonna get her
you know i was really covert about this
[ __ ]
snuck it around i just i brought
everything into the garage
this year right sorry what the [ __ ] was
that you know what [ __ ] where you open
your mouth and you just make a [ __ ]
noise did you just hear that
sounded like there was a ferret that was
like some something in the back of my
throat while i continued to talk
sounded like a little cat did you hear
that
you know do you realize like back if i
did that back in like the [ __ ] 1700s
they'd they'd be like drowning me
thinking i was a witch
i was like possessed or i had a [ __ ]
tapeworm or something
jesus christ some of these [ __ ]
broads on on social media thinking
they're not being heard how do you think
the [ __ ] people felt back then well
if you have to compare ourselves
to the salem witch trial aren't you
really proving our point
[Music]
that was the hedge clippers trim in the
bush there
um
they broke anyways um
plowing ahead here uh by the way i've
keep
i promoted this on on joe rogan to uh
the patrice o'neill comedy benefit
still promoting that is february tuesday
february 19
2019 get your ass to the [ __ ] city
all right come on down great benefit big
jake
oakers michelle wolf
rich vos [ __ ]
cypher sounds myself that's good it's
going to be a cavalcade a comedy
for the best stand-up comedian i ever
saw in my life all proceeds go to
benefit
all the people he's taking care of his
family and all that and it's been a very
successful thing
we keep his name alive and what not
um all right with that you know what i
actually got to watch a bruins game the
other night
uh i got watch most of it i watch most
of it and then uh
being a dad comes in you know i saw uh
the first two periods of the bruins four
to nothing win
over the canadians you know we were up
two to nothing and i missed the fourth
period
third period sorry and uh
you know one of my friends from montreal
comedy festival texts me he goes you're
watching this game
and i knew it was the third period and i
was like well i got i'm assuming you
guys tied it up if you [ __ ] called me
and to his credit he didn't he you know
texted me he to his credit he didn't
the man did not he was letting me know
that we played [ __ ] great then i saw
the highlights that last [ __ ]
marshawn gold and
number four that little bing bang boom
all around the horn everybody touches it
wow
all those little frenchies with their
[ __ ] crying into their little
handkerchiefs with their silly socks oh
i love it
going into their building
four to nothing so they're probably
playing tonight i have no idea but i
gotta go and
i gotta go inside for [ __ ] supper i
still call it supper
back in the day that's what we called
sit down for something
your mother would ring the [ __ ]
dinner bell and everybody would come
running in like cattle
right all [ __ ] filthy for being
outside and there it was chippy fun
toast
uh chicken ala king
you know i don't think a king eats like
this
um anyways let's plow ahead here uh
liverpool my [ __ ]
my [ __ ] adopted goddamn team i almost
[ __ ]
miss this game they're playing oh my god
they're playing the wolves
jesus [ __ ] christ not the wolves
how the [ __ ] is that a professional
franchise you got some stupid jersey
with like a w
on it we get it you know you couldn't
write the whole thing they can't afford
to have the o-l-v-e-s
on there right does that spell wolves or
is it w-o-l-f-s
wolf's i don't know they'd say
everything different over there
oregano oregano you know
what else do they say tomato oregano
uh all the spices they say differently
what's the other
rosemarie no that's not the one what the
[ __ ]
time they say the same way
there's another one there's another one
just the ones basel
oregano basel tomatoes
and you just want to be like stop doing
that you want to say that they're wrong
but they did it first
so they were right why the [ __ ] did we
switch we switched all the accents on
everything
and i believe that was our [ __ ] you
right to england after we kicked their
[ __ ] red coated asses
all the way back to their island all the
way back
right and i just think that our little
rebellion was not only are we kicking
you out of the country
that you first [ __ ] occupied and took
over
not only will we continue the genocide
that you started
right we're gonna we're gonna change the
accent
on the english language right
you say uh automobile
we're gonna say automobile i know if we
do that i have no idea
um anyways uh
the [ __ ] was that i hear
goddamn noises now i don't know if i'm
going crazy or what
i will tell you what's driving me
[ __ ] crazy
is this year i you know i thought i was
being a smart guy oh who's this who's a
tough guy who's a smart guy right
i went out and i bought a christmas tree
like when it was still november
you know so now i'm watering this thing
and i gotta missed it every goddamn
morning
to make sure it's not all brown and dead
by the time
[ __ ] christmas comes along our wreath
is on the on the front door is already
dying
you know and my wife went all out you
know what i mean like great mothers do
she went all out but i got more goddamn
[ __ ] i'm running around
you know i i'm the water boy i gotta
water it i missed it i'm talking to it
no you look good you look good no you're
gonna be one of the trees that lives
after christmas you don't just lying to
him
like a [ __ ] dirtbag right so i didn't
have a lot of time the other day
and i'm running around the [ __ ]
kitchen table and we got this stupid
[ __ ] potted plant that literally has
a concrete
plant planter whatever the [ __ ] house
that the roots are in whatever you call
it right
and that was on the floor because of the
christmas decorations on the table
and i ran around the table and just
punted that thing
concrete [ __ ] block with my
my pinky toe on my left foot and jesus
[ __ ] christ
it was like barty the dinosaur purple
within two hours and it was like
half of my foot my foot looked like i
got run over by a car
now you know obviously i did some damage
but most of it has to be
my most of it is my complexion you know
being uh a uh [ __ ]
you know redhead i'm borderline
like transparent like i'm always getting
marks on my body and like
late at night like i go to bed and my
wife be like what is that what is that
on your
what is you know [ __ ] claw mark on my
side did you get into a fight with an
alley cat yeah no i think i uh
think i leaned up against the
refrigerator
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened and
then you know what's weird is if you
hurt yourself and you don't remember
what happened
you press down on it and then you're
like oh and he takes you right back to
that moment oh that's right
that's [ __ ] right yeah i was i was at
the the [ __ ] poster
oh by the way jesus christ i went to the
post office i was trying to get all my
[ __ ] gifts out
and uh you cannot [ __ ] go there
the only way you can [ __ ] go there is
if you have everything done
i went there i needed a box and
i needed to and then i needed the
[ __ ] the peanuts or whatever to put
it in there so what i was whatever i was
going to put in there was going to slide
around and break
and i needed tape to close the box it
should just like it's just
it's that last chopper out of vietnam
and i was happy
that i went down there i i found
somebody to help me out
you know i got the box i got the tape
and then they said they had nothing to
put in there
to make sure my gifts to my nephews and
nieces wouldn't [ __ ] slide around
and i i just i just i said [ __ ] it
i said all right thank you i set the
tape down i put the box back where it
belonged
i walked out like a gentleman while i
[ __ ]
i went a little tourette's underneath it
god damn [ __ ] [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] do you have [ __ ] boxes
and tape but you don't have the the last
ingredient the most important ingredient
or the last piece of the puzzle i should
say the box is probably the most
important ingredient well then you have
to have tape i mean they work together
like a great comedy team dare i say
right
like bob hope and bing crosby the guys
who evidently created the [ __ ]
the buddy movie you know
which has now been hijacked by all these
females and all these movies acting like
they're breaking ground it's like you're
just doing the [ __ ] we already did
there's nothing new here ladies you know
why don't you reinvent the buddy [ __ ]
movie
before i gotta listen to you calling
each other a bunch of [ __ ] heroes
what do you think about that
hey uh this is the thing that fascinated
me because i was
reading this celtics book and
some of the [ __ ] teams that they were
playing like you know playing
syracuse and rochester stuff i had heard
about before
but um when they they were talking what
the [ __ ] is this
they were talking about playing like the
uh
what are now the atlanta hawks and i
knew that they were in saint louis but i
didn't
realize that they were in milwaukee
before that
all right let's see here atlanta hawks
yeah they were it
this is this is their their history they
were the buffalo bisons
then for one season and then they moved
or maybe a half a season
then they moved to the tri-cities in
iowa
which are now the quad cities i believe
and they became the tri-city blackhawks
then they moved to milwaukee in 1951
and became the milwaukee hawks then in
1955 they moved to saint louis and
became the saint louis hawks
and then in 1968 they moved
to uh atlanta and became the atlanta
hawks they've been there for 50 years
but they've moved
five times and i always thought the
sacramento kings
which i can't remember if they were the
cincinnati royals and then the kansas
city kings and then the sacramento kings
i couldn't remember hang on a second let
me get to this because i got this
[ __ ] website here that has all the
franchises that moved
if i can get it to work here please
please there's people listening national
hockey league where the [ __ ] is the nba
oh jesus christ come on national
basketball associate the tri-city hawks
blackhawks played their home games in
moline
and rock island illinois and davenport
iowa
moved to milwaukee became the hawks then
in 55 they moved to st
louis okay and then the detroit
pittston's with a fort wayne pistons
until 1957 rochester royals
moved to cincinnati and then where the
[ __ ] did they go from there
because this goes year by year so they
became the sacramento kings yeah
they were the rochester's seagrams what
the [ __ ] is that
anyways rochester pros then they became
the rochester royals then they moved
cincinnati royals kansas city slash
omaha kings kansas city kings
sacramento kings and then i think
the syracuse team moved to san diego and
became the san diego clippers
where the [ __ ] is it the syracuse
nationals moved to philadelphia and
became the 76ers okay
so who became the la clippers the san
diego clippers
oh the buffalo braves moved to san diego
and became the clippers
that's what it is oh no it's the
rochester royals i don't know i'm a
[ __ ] nerd i love that [ __ ]
then i go online and see if i can find a
tri-cities blackhawks t-shirt
like they ever [ __ ] sold one of those
i bet it's a minor league hockey team
now
try city
come on come on bill you can write it
black hawks
t-shirt here we go somebody makes it you
know somebody makes it
mitchell and ness
chicago blackhawks try city blackhawks
there it is everyone
like myself would think oh is that where
the chicago blackhawks first played and
they'd be like oh no no no that's not
that's not the case
old dad leave me alone
um yeah they got the
they got the dude did you just see them
the [ __ ] kid
they got it wearing it was like 21
[ __ ] years old
similar designs look at this they got
all the old ones here anyways
trust the process oh
boy i didn't want to know who the [ __ ]
said that
uh oh there's a cool lebron one where
they make his beard like the state of
california
do you realize if the lakers don't win
it this year this will be the first
decade they haven't won a [ __ ]
championship since the [ __ ] 1960s
70s 80s 90s 2000s they won four decades
in a row celtics won 50s
60s 70s 80s
then went four decades right they were
70s 80s 90s
2000 four oh yeah no one's ever done
five no one's ever done five can you see
can you tell i'm all [ __ ] talked out
from rogan's podcast we did like [ __ ]
two and a half hours
i'm sitting here wondering what the hell
to talk about i can read some
advertising i could read some
advertising
by the way i'm not farting continually
i'm just sitting in a leather chair
i just realized
look at that leather chair plush
leather chair one chair one chair
my little [ __ ] podcast area here
finally because now we have the kid i
can't do it the way i used to in the
[ __ ] bedroom and [ __ ] screaming and
yelling we can't have that
bill we feel we can't have you be who
you
are in your own home anymore butcher box
everybody
butcher box delivers that's a great name
for like a [ __ ] female wrestler
butcher box you know or finishing move
is she jumps up in the air and [ __ ]
puts her claim in your face
butcher box delivers healthy 100
grass-fed and grass-finished b
free-range organic chicken and the
[ __ ]
mother of them all the holy grail
for all you carnivores out there
heritage bread
pork the incredible oh my god do i love
that stuff
the incredible quality of butcher box
means start with the
commitment starting sorry with the
commitment to raising animals humanely
and free of antibiotics and hormones
telling they look beautiful before
they're murdered cooked
with peace of mind knowing you're eating
healthy high quality meat
each box comes with at least 8 to 11
pounds of meat
which is enough for 24 individual sized
meals
even for you size queens out there you
can choose from five different box types
all beef
beef and chicken beef and pork mixed box
custom box i feel like the mix box is
the progressive liberal box
where custom box is more like you know
hardcore right
you know i only want beef uh
in my neighborhood let's you let you
choose your own goddamn cuts it's
delicious for 20
off your first box and a package of free
bacon
in every box for the life of your
subscription meaning whenever you order
some food
you're getting some free bacon never pay
for bacon again
go to butcherbox.com enter bur at
checkout
that's 20 off your first box and a
package of free bacon
in every box for life for the life of
your subscription
by going to butcherbox.com and entering
burr
at checkout um i got a
hats off to my wife we had some uh we
had like this really mature
like get-together of like you know four
or five different couples
and they came over and my wife just did
it up you know
hired these people to cater it they made
all this great food
you know the booze was flowing everyone
was having a good time and i sat there
she's like come on man it's a holiday
party yeah i have just had one drink
have one drink i said i will i'm
starting with the ginger ale right i
just kept putting it off and putting it
off and putting it off right
and then all of a sudden was the end of
night we were all sitting there smoking
cigars
and uh then all of a sudden the night
was over and i didn't drink
everybody had a good time and i've
almost done it
i only have uh i got a couple more
holiday parties oh i got a tough one
i got a tough one coming up a good
friend of mine comedian i'm not gonna
say who the [ __ ] it is but he has a
party coming up oh this is gonna be
tough
and no it's not that gutter dweller joe
derosa
oh joe derosa loves a gutter loves a
gutter
you know he sees a curb he just he's
nuzzles up to it like he's laying with
his own mutter
his own mutter um but anyways i always
get
a little bit sad this time of the
holidays you know because i know that
it's almost over
i like this time of year you know
everybody just kind of sits back it's
like you know what i [ __ ] love you
man
[ __ ] appreciate you being in my life
man you know
you know they got the [ __ ] lights
it's just you just look around like why
can't it be like this all the time
why can't work be like all right relax
you know and everybody just chills out
and just
says how much they like each other why
can't we do you'd get bored of it i
guess after a while
they can't have like you know sort of a
summer christmas time
holiday hanukkah kwanzaa [ __ ] thing
you gotta wait once once a [ __ ] year
then it starts all over again
january 2nd or january 3rd this is going
to be
this company's biggest quarter ever
we need you all to buckle down and not
go home
you will not see your children
when you leave for work you'll be
sleeping when you come home they will be
asleep
you will be a stranger in your own house
so this year we can sell the most
widgets we've ever sold ever
i'll tell you right now if you got a
problem there's a door
the internet has made this industry more
competitive than it has ever been
i need killers in this room
you gonna cry maggie huh
who else what about you greg heard
you're all [ __ ] sensitive
get you a [ __ ] box of tampons for the
first [ __ ] quarter what did you do
less
last quarter you did [ __ ] you know can
you imagine if you had that [ __ ] life
just imagine that [ __ ] life
getting yelled at you know you know that
famous scene and glenn gary glenn ross
alec baldwin comes in and starts yelling
at people i can't [ __ ] hear myself
god damn it i gotta get this fixed um
this would be such
a great stalking stuffer why didn't i
tell [ __ ] santa i wanted this
oh here comes santa claus here comes
santa claus he's back from radio shack
he got you the [ __ ] headphone jack
that you needed
what is this thing even called i'm gonna
you know what i'm gonna do people in
in [ __ ] honor of the new year
and what i plan on doing which you
wouldn't know from that last little
comedy skit that i did there
and by the way that was all written up i
memorized all those lines
um uh you know i'm going to try to
[ __ ] chill out in the next [ __ ]
year you know what i mean
so anyways in honor of that i'm in
solving problems rather than complaining
about them i'm i'm
going to let you guys listen to me order
this is the highlight of your [ __ ]
week i know it is this is how
self-involved i am you're going to
listen to me order
this [ __ ] cock-sucking goddamn thing
that i need here
what would you call this thing uh
the rotisserie you know this is
basically like the chick
in you know a porno she's getting banged
from behind
and uh you know she's performing the old
[ __ ] uh
and how you been up front right and you
know someone's gonna have a bigger dick
right so one of them's bigger the other
one's smaller
what do you call this thing the
rotisserie uh
core jack i don't [ __ ] know uh
headphone i'm gonna go with head phone
adapter
and it's gonna take me to [ __ ]
wikipedia why the [ __ ] would it do that
it's in my default settings i gotta
figure out a [ __ ] headphone adapter
oh no oh no no no that's not the one i
need
let's see images come on you [ __ ]
bastard
come on you [ __ ] bastard uh oh do i
need
no it's not duel oh my god there it is
and it's at radio shack
three and a half millimeter male to
female what do you call this [ __ ]
thing
oh my god i know the name this is like a
cold case file
3.5 millimeter male to female headphone
adapter
all right let me go let me go to [ __ ]
amazon because i don't know how to do it
with radio shack do those guys deliver
to do they have the drones i don't
[ __ ] know
all right where the [ __ ] is it oh where
did it go
oh you know what i did i didn't open a
new window oh grandpa hey
i don't understand the internet oh no i
did
well where the [ __ ] did it go
oh there it is would you like 15
off no thanks i'd like full price 3.5
millimeter male to female headphone
adapter
let's see here
3.5 millimeter
male 2 female
headphone adapter
come on man one time one time make it
happen make it happen that's not what
the [ __ ] that is
oh look at those ones those ones look
like they're made out of chrome
that's that's it right there
that's it seven dollars can you [ __ ]
believe it
all this [ __ ] moaning complaining i
could have had this done
you know you know people a lot of times
in life
you know the things that we're the most
afraid of a lot of times they seem like
mountains and they're really you're just
stepping up onto a curb
wait what do you mean 125 dollars what
the [ __ ] william get the gift i don't
want a [ __ ] gift card
proceed to check out get away from me
can i just can i just walk out of here
please can i just [ __ ] do that
place your order bam
order place all this time bitching
all this time that's it done i just
[ __ ] i did it i did all this [ __ ]
screaming and yelling
you know i just feel like that just to
be a performer
isn't enough for me i feel like i should
be this vessel
who is it come on in
oh just when christmas couldn't get any
better who's that
is that my little buddy hey
how you doing come here
oh yeah don't mess up my notes on that
script that doesn't work right now
can i get a hug please hi hey
hi hey hey football
can you say hockey can you say
basketball
can you say baseball
um yeah just don't ever knock all those
cards over how you guys doing
the two most beautiful ladies in my life
how are you i've been bitching about
this 3.5 millimeter male to female
uh headphone jack and i finally got it
fixed what did you guys do today
we just came from uh getting some
ingredients for christmas dinner please
what are you gonna make um
am i plugged in yes you are plugged in
uh we're gonna make a lamb
so i got a rack of lamb oh nice and i
had him cut it up and we're just going
to freeze it until it's ready because
it's going to be
a mad house when we go on christmas eve
or
can you say strawberry can you say
football can you say hi can you say
merry christmas
yeah i don't know if you can say that
wow um here i know how to keep you
occupied while we're in here all right
well we're just doing something i didn't
realize i had all these that's that
script i'm writing so
i get up what's this oh those are those
are dad dust keys
can you say daddy's keys okay okay you
say dada's car
uh
i hit an orange cone in my car and all
of a sudden the engine light went on
i was on the highway and there's this
random orange cone and i couldn't swerve
away from it or
i'd cause an accident so i just drove
over and went underneath the car
and i was getting off the highway and it
was i just heard it under the car
what's that minnie mouse
you want to go watch minnie mouse huh
what do you say
football what do you say you say please
now what do you say
thanks please and thanks that's right
you're gonna be a good kid oh oh i get a
kiss
and mama yeah she's the best hey you're
the best
you're the best mwah oh my god
[Music]
something about minnie mouse okay
just don't mess that's you that's you
yes it is yes it is all right we gotta
wrap this thing up because
i want to play with you kiddo all right
and we're gonna watch some
football football
strawberry yeah
hey what does the dog say what's the
duck say
what does the cow say a moo
so she talks like trump the biggest a
brain
um what does a horse say
what is uh what does the rooster say
what's the cat say no no
uh what does the sheep say
what's the bear say all right
you're a smartie oh you just shrug the
shoulder like that was nothing
it's like give me something hard shall
we go
should we say bye bye okay
all right say bye-bye
can you say i love you
[Music]
that's how we
there you go all right eventually you're
going to put that together and melt my
heart even more all right
i love both you guys but i got to wrap
this up hey you guys thank you for
listening
have a great week and i can't say what i
usually say
so merry christmas
enjoy the music and the next half hour
bonus of the uh
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning thank you to joe rogan
for
having me on the show today
[Music]
magnolia
is
[Music]
don't forget to hang up your sock cause
just
exactly at 12 o'clock he'll
[Music]
christmas [ __ ] trees ooby dooby
see that's the [ __ ] song i was trying
to remember from last week and i want to
thank all the podcast listeners
for letting me know that that was andy
williams
happy holidays slash the holiday
season it's not until the second verse
where he goes hoop dee doo
and humpty dumpty stick up a suck up a
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
you know see exactly how i said it then
they had those [ __ ]
women in the background
you're telling me you couldn't write a
[ __ ] song back then i mean jesus
christ
maybe because it's so simple it sounds
so simple that you think he could do it
i i don't know
so anyways it is ah [ __ ] why did i play
that now i'm gonna be singing that the
whole goddamn podcast again i don't like
to repeat myself
at least not on purpose what's going on
it's bill burr it is the monday morning
podcast
for monday uh december 20th
oh my god only five more days till
christmas
i only have half shut up you [ __ ]
all right i'm not even this angry this
week i'm just trying to figure out how
i'm going to situate myself on the bed
i don't want to put my laptop in my lap
you know what i mean
why would you why won't you put it in
your lap
it's called a laptop um this is why
because it gives off radiation and i
like my balls
i think the illuminati came up with the
laptop you know
and they know we're too stupid to stick
it exactly where they want us to put it
so they can thin out the [ __ ] herd
so they go you know with their evil
voices why don't we just call it the
laptop
we call it they let up they put it in
their lap and they [ __ ] die the
infidels
that was half arab half italian so make
sure i get notes from both of you
um yes it is december 20th
i just came off of a fabulous week
out in brea california and i want to
tell you guys something if you're ever
in a situation where you have a lot of
vacation time
and you're just like [ __ ] where the hell
can i go
you know if you only go around once in
this world where can i go
to vacation to summer is that what rich
people say
we live in the city and we summer out in
the hamptons
i'd love to summer somewhere wouldn't
that be awesome
jesus christ how much [ __ ] money do
you have to have to have two homes
this is where i live during the year and
then i summer
we spend our winters down in barbados
you know we're doing what visiting the
[ __ ] money that you're not paying
taxes
taxes on you know i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't know what i'm talking about here
i was onto something there and then i
completely lost it because i thought i
wasn't recording here
um oh i know i was out in break
california this weekend and i got to
tell you i had a
miserable experience the last couple
times i went there and the only reason
why i was miserable
is because nobody showed up and lo and
behold
this time i came out there the [ __ ]
place was packed all weekend and i had
one of the best weekends
of uh of 2010 so i want to thank
everybody
who came out to my shows uh out at the
improv in brea california i actually had
some people from l.a came out
and uh i had like 12 uh
mexicans different mexican fans coming
up saying you have some latino fans
okay hang in there we will spread the
word out to ontario
so i want to thank you guys gracias the
only word i know
muchos gracias rosetta stone
i'm a rio
uh thank you very much and yellow that's
my only spanish words
yeah [ __ ] like that that i've seen in
like cartoons when i was a kid
um so anyways i don't know what the [ __ ]
to talk about this week because
uh i am technically i'm on vacation
like axel foley and beverly hills cop
i'm not investigating anything i'm out
here in la with my mumford
[ __ ] sweatshirt you know what i
realized i just realized this podcast is
gonna suck
you know why i have too much other [ __ ]
on my mind because uh as much as i'm
mocking
people who haven't started their
shopping i'm one of those people
i haven't started it yet and i really
[ __ ] up
because i did like six weekends in a row
so i just focused on the road work
and i did not deal with the fact that i
haven't done
any sort of christmas shopping yet so
now i have to go out there today it's
[ __ ] raining
i've been in this weather since i went
to seattle right after thanksgiving and
i'm ready to blow my [ __ ] brains out
i went to seattle and i also went to san
francisco and all those [ __ ] [ __ ]
were just like oh you bring the you
bring the bad weather with you
you know i don't know it was great last
week so you know what
considering i bought the droid phone
does anybody know how to shut that off
droid
every time you turn it on my phone says
that i brought the droid incredible and
every time i turn it on
first of all it takes 10 minutes for it
to turn on and then about
you know eight minutes in it goes droid
and i don't think there's a way to shut
it off that's one of those [ __ ]
advertising things
make it nice and loud and obnoxious
so everyone around will hear it and be
like ooh i want my phone to do that
right i'm still waiting for that like i
hope that phone does not take over as
much as i love it
because uh i fly too much you know and
at the end of the flights when it's okay
to turn your cell phones back on
i don't want to hear like drawer drawer
droid
on the [ __ ] plane but you know i'm
going to um
but anyways yeah i haven't i haven't
started in my christmas shopping
and uh i don't want to be that douche
just goes out
and gets the gift certificates you know
that you know that person you go out you
buy them something
thoughtful what are they into uh what
did i hear or mention that they wanted
or something like that you put a lot of
thought
you drive around now that is it right
drive over here that isn't right
bam and then you find it they're like oh
man thanks a lot
right and they give you like a [ __ ]
yeah you wait to see what they got you
right did you put some thought in
do you feel this way about me too and
what do they do they hand you a gift
certificate to the [ __ ] olive garden
you know it's like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know
i drove all over [ __ ] town and you
just you just and not even a good
restaurant that's
that's another thing too um if somebody
gives you a gift certificate to a
restaurant don't [ __ ] go
don't even [ __ ] go all right what
sort of respectable
restaurant gives out gift certificates
you know what i mean that's that's
you just like one step above fast food
you know what douche bag of the week
is anybody who goes out and does
christmas shop but it just gets a bunch
of [ __ ] gift certificate hey
you go you [ __ ] figure out what you
want it's some money why don't you just
come in and take a [ __ ] handful of
cash
and throw it on the floor like of some
goddamn horror and watch me crawl around
on my hands and knees picking it up
you know like i just gave you a bad lap
dance
but you got enough money to not [ __ ] to
management yeah you have really that's
what i get is you [ __ ] hundred
don't spend it all in one place
all right you [ __ ] cheap bastards i'm
talking to you
and you and you there's got to be at
least three people on this podcast
that do that [ __ ] you [ __ ] tight
[ __ ]
right and then what do you do you gather
up all your nice gifts that people
put thought into and you just you know
walk out of the house you know you don't
give a [ __ ]
right [ __ ] it right
it's just the drinking water we can pour
the [ __ ] in there
will that get me the corner office
i swear to god if somebody gets me a
[ __ ] gift certificate
this weekend i'm gonna do some not this
is christmas this weekend
five days away yeah it'd be saturday i'm
gonna take that [ __ ] thing oh thanks
a lot and i'm gonna slice their jugular
like james bond level [ __ ] paper cut
and just watch that blood
right off the side of their [ __ ] neck
all right so you learned something about
me
you already knew i was an angry son of a
[ __ ] but i hate
gift certificates i can't stand them
i would rather get an ugly sweater
from an older relative than than a
[ __ ] gift certificate that's just
you know it that's just the [ __ ] tap
out
you know sorry man i've been really busy
oh really oh i've been laying in a
hammock all year you lazy [ __ ]
no you don't give a [ __ ]
why am i such a [ __ ] dick
somebody i knew every year would get me
a [ __ ] gift certificate and you know
i i should have just gave it right back
to him
i never did i always gave him a nice
gift thinking ah you're gonna you're
gonna notice right
nothing nothing
holy [ __ ] all right there you go there's
your first rant for the week did that
make you feel better
i'd like to why don't i have why don't i
have a podcast where i give thanks
i give thanks to everyone who came out
to my shows this year
you know i give thanks to the universe
for allowing me to
[ __ ] up enough in my personal life to uh
bless me with an
a new hour of material
i gotta tell you man my [ __ ] act is
right where i needed to be
and uh my next gig isn't until
uh the weekend i believe of january 13th
um i'm gonna be in atlantic city with uh
this is the show
jim norton put this thing together it's
jim norton
myself jim brewer and david tell all on
one show
all right the miami heat the mount
rushmore if you will
of uh stand-up of uh stand-up comedy i
can't say mount rushmore that'd be
all-time greats let's go with miami heat
all right
let's go with that how would we say that
so anyways that's my next show so i have
this weird thing where i'm off for like
a month but i also have to stay sharp so
my girl's all excited that i have a
month off and i'm actually doing a show
tonight
and i was trying to tell her that i i
have to stay sharp
you know i got to stay on my toes i
can't just sit around
[ __ ] roasting chestnuts does anybody
do that anymore has anybody ever had a
chestnut
chestnuts roasting on an open fire
jack frost nipping at your nose
there's no internet or [ __ ] cell
phones so we have to
talk to one another um
all right what you know something
something i mentioned they're actually
tied into something that somebody was
talking about oh they were talking about
die hard
fans i'm talking about sports here
somebody said
bill just like the yankees the celtics
purchased the last
championship with kevin garnett i love
when people do half-assed research
you know didn't you forget a couple
other guys that we also bought
um it's not
it's not even the purchasing of garnett
that bothers me it's the delusion
boston's fans
have when they cheer for garnett that
[ __ ] kissed the shamrock in the
center of the court like it was his
homecoming
like he was from boston like he yearned
for playing for that team
and boston's fans ate that [ __ ] up
totally bought
into that [ __ ] uh when in actuality
it was just another purchase for a
championship
how do you feel knowing your fellow
bostonians got duped
uh the [ __ ] fan base i see in boston
makes me want to puke in my soup
it happens in a bunch of other cities
too
uh sorry i i can't read out loud and i'm
also reading this at a [ __ ] angle
let's get some [ __ ] stomach cancer
here put the laptop here
uh where was where was i uh you have
diehard fans for all your teams but
they're few and far
in between few and far between sirs how
you say that
uh then you have just a bunch of
stragglers who suddenly come out of the
woodwork when their team's on top i live
in new york and now in la in the past
eight years i've noticed an influx
influx of pats fans in both of those
cities all of a sudden everyone is proud
to be a patriots fan
uh where were these [ __ ] in the 90s
same goes for laker fans where were
those [ __ ]
with the flag on the car ass uh
with the flag in the car [ __ ] in the
90s explain this to me bill
and go ahead and [ __ ] on as many
front-running new yorkers los angeles
and miami schmucks
all you like yeah yeah dude you're
basically explaining
uh yeah that's how it works
yeah where were all the yankee fans in
the 80s exactly
you can't say where were all the
patriots fans in the 90s because once we
got bill parcells everybody jumped on
board
and then when pete carroll came in after
parcells [ __ ] us
that fat [ __ ] that fat
[ __ ] egomaniac who never won a
championship without bill belichick as
his defensive coordinator
uh you want me to cook the dinner you
gotta let me buy the groceries he says
that
right before our super bowl and puts his
[ __ ] house up for sale what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] we're overrated bill parcells
if you want your uniforms changed and
you want to make it to the playoffs
he's your guy but if you want to win the
super bowl you got you better have bill
belichick on your staff
all right yeah yeah you bandwagon fans
bandwagon fans are are uh the majority
of the fan base there's no reason to
build stadiums as big as they are if
they're actually talking about die hard
fans
you'd only need like uh one level you
know
you could have those old school like
high school stadiums you know where the
wind whips through
the end zones uh yeah absolutely that
everybody is guilty of that and um
basketball i hate to say it has followed
what the uh what baseball has been doing
where you just sort of try to buy the
buy the championship every year and it's
really uh
free agency i guess it's kind of the
player's fault you know what it was
it was an over correction it was before
free agency
you know the owners were like the owner
in um
what is that called the perfect stallion
what the [ __ ] that i can never name
the robert redford movie the natural
perfect stallion how the [ __ ] did i get
that
[Laughter]
i can't remember [ __ ] i can never
remember the names of actors in movies
so i just whatever
first thing i think of i just [ __ ]
throw it out there uh the natural yeah
the owners were like that they totally
[ __ ] owned you
and um that's why the the [ __ ] white
sox threw the world series in 1919
that's what opened the door to that is
they were getting so underpaid and they
were scumbag pieces of [ __ ] those two
[ __ ] things
um so then free agency came around
and uh now there's been like a total
over correction
um and the players are tol seem to be
completely in control
and they can just all pile on one
[ __ ] team i don't know i don't like
it i don't like it yeah the celtics
bought the championship apps are [ __ ]
lootly
uh but you know it's one of those deals
what are they supposed to do that's what
the lakers were buying them too
you know what are we supposed to do sit
back and watch them buy all these
[ __ ] championships and we're not
supposed to go out and purchase one
you know kobe bryant's sitting out there
can't win [ __ ] so they buy him shaq and
phil
jackson [ __ ] gary payton robert orry
[ __ ] carl malone
who else i i don't watch hoop every time
i turn it on there's another [ __ ] guy
the guy who beat up the crowd
run our test that guy what
what what the [ __ ] are the celtics
supposed to do you know
it'd be nice if they all sat down and
just said look this is [ __ ] stupid
let's go back to the way it was but i
just think that that's the way it is
so anyways yeah they just pile on i
think garnett kissed the floor because
he was sick of playing in minnesota and
he knew he finally had a chance
to uh to win a championship
after being the [ __ ] guy for all
those years out there in minnesota and
always coming up short so
i don't know i don't [ __ ] i don't
know i don't know [ __ ] about basketball
but yeah you're basically yeah die hard
fans die hard fans hang in there
but i even think die hard fans are full
of [ __ ] there's a couple
that will actually sit there come on man
you're gonna be honest i'm a die hard
fan your team is going 2 and 14
you're actually sitting down watching
that [ __ ]
you know sometimes you're such a
die-hard fan you can't go
you can't watch you know i didn't watch
the celtics
i went to a celtics game the year before
we bought all those guys to win a
championship
we played the toronto raptors i had like
courtside [ __ ] seats and i almost
fell asleep
and it was just sad looking at the
parquet floor and looking at the
shamrock and just seeing
it was it was you know it was hard to
watch
that doesn't mean i don't love the
celtics but you know
sometimes you got to look away and you
know what you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you do the same thing stop acting like
you're all high and mighty you just hate
the patriots
and you're sick of seeing them be honest
with yourself all you sports fans
who the [ __ ] ever saw anybody in a
sports bar
with the new orleans saints jersey on
ever
30 years of watching football i never
[ __ ] saw it and then last year
there's like a whole gang of them going
who dat who dat
who that think they're going to beat
them saints
it's like where the [ __ ] did you guys
come from
the saints were borderline they were
like an expansion franchise for
like 40 years they couldn't even afford
a kicker
with two whole feet they had a kicker
with one and a half [ __ ] feet
that's that's that's how [ __ ] broke
those guys were
you know then they brought that football
out there with the helium in there so
they could have a feel-good story
oh by the way um did you see how the
jets
when they got busted for cheating that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] on the jets go with the patriots are
doing it too
that right there is known as a
pulling a kobe when you do that [ __ ]
that's called
shaq [ __ ] around on his wife too you
know when you're down at the police
station
dude you don't ever do that all right
when you get busted for some [ __ ]
you go into mr blonde mode you shut your
[ __ ] mouth and you do your goddamn
time you don't start dragging other
people in
it was so passive aggressive i'm not
trying to get anybody in trouble i'm
just you know if you just
you know look at the tape i mean it's
all there
which was such a stoop that there's no
rule against lining up people there you
can stand on the sideline
you can all stand there doing handstands
if you want that's not what you got
busted for
you green [ __ ] you got busted for
sticking your [ __ ] knee out
evidently on purpose how wrong was i i
tried to be nice last week
and i defended that douche and it turns
out uh
i don't know i like how they tried to
act like that was his decision and his
decision alone
that guy actually he should that guy the
strength and conditioning coach that
guy's a solid guy because he just he
took
he took the blame for that one the
strength and conditioning coach
he the only guy he's he's the guy like
as far as money makers he's just above a
[ __ ] cheerleader
and he's saying like he's on the
sideline hey listen guys everybody
[ __ ] line up
the private over there they're blaming
the private you know
give me a [ __ ] break but i i think
sticking his knee out was definitely
his decision but as far as lining up on
on the side i don't give a [ __ ]
so i love it so the jets cheated and
this week the panthers had somebody get
up and drill
drill someone coming down the sideline
see this is what it's all coming out i
love it
after all these years of people saying
the patriots are cheaters like no one
else is doing it
like the yankees weren't all taking
[ __ ] roids
along with the [ __ ] reds everybody
cheats did you guys watch that 30 for 30
on smu
and how the entire southwest conference
football was played
i hate to say it during the week of
christmas but there's no santa claus
everybody [ __ ] cheats
everybody cheats
what song is that remember that from
[ __ ] sesame street everybody sleeps
and they show like turtles sleeping and
you sit there almost tearing up not even
knowing what the [ __ ] you were crying
about
you know because you already knew it you
could sense it even as a six-year-old
that the world was gonna be full of a
bunch of selfish [ __ ]
hey you know something i have a video
for you this week how many [ __ ]
agonizing minutes am i into this podcast
22 [ __ ] minutes jesus christ i gotta
be honest with you people sometimes this
podcast is easy
and other times i feel like i'm
shoveling wet snow
and uh this is one of these times i feel
like i'm shoveling wet [ __ ] snow
uh i'm sick of talking about football i
can't talk about it any [ __ ] more
uh thank you to uh green bay wisconsin
though
i do want to say thank you for that
christmas gift for allowing us to win
that game that we shouldn't have won
yesterday
and uh do you guys realize i actually
bet the patriots
after telling you guys all you've given
14 and a half [ __ ] points
i bought into the hype you know what a
[ __ ]
all year i've been saying i hate our
[ __ ] defense our defense lets up 24
to 30 points every [ __ ] game
we have two good weeks in a row i even
said last week on the podcast you think
i'm buying into this [ __ ] like we're
gonna win a super bowl
you don't just play two good games in a
row and [ __ ] wipe out 11 bad ones
and after saying all of that what do i
do
i [ __ ] bet the patriots because their
[ __ ] quarterback was out
and i'm a fan of lsu i don't ever
remember that guy [ __ ] doing anything
you know what it was that guy played at
lsu right before i started watching
college football but my experience of
watching lsu
is they have [ __ ] uh they always have
two quarterbacks
a white dude and a black dude and they
just they just sort of i don't know what
they do they just they uh they just
switch them off
and it's not the same guys every every
[ __ ] year they got a new white dude a
new black dude
and they just uh ah put the white guy in
there ah he's too [ __ ] white
look at him taking that sack stick the
black guy in there
jesus christ he won't stand in the
pocket get the white guy back in there
i'm telling you if they could somehow
amalga just stick those two guys
together
ah that probably wouldn't work wouldn't
it i know it worked for paul mccartney
and michael
jackson when they they sang that [ __ ]
song
was that one of the worst songs ever
wait a minute was that him who sang
ebony and ivory
that was them right i was thinking of
eddie murphy and he made it stevie
wonder and frank sinatra that was the
sketch
was that one of the worst [ __ ] songs
ever
ebony and ivory
somebody looked at the piano and just
came up with that corn ball [ __ ] you
know what i mean it's like yeah we all
want everybody to get along
but do you have to try to make us throw
up in the process
[Laughter]
why is happy [ __ ] so
nauseating can anybody explain that to
me during the week of [ __ ] christmas
you know what is it about watching
like a kid trip and fall and start
crying and then looking for his mother
what is it about that that's so [ __ ]
funny
you know when they get up and they're
crying so bad that they're not even
making any noise
[Music]
[Laughter]
it just [ __ ] makes me laugh
you know watching my dog get so excited
that it wants to go outside
and and it goes to make a quick you know
[ __ ] barry sanders cut
and its legs front legs go out from
underneath him and i hear him hit its
jaw off the floor
gets up and [ __ ] does that little
harlem shake to try to
it's just [ __ ] funny i don't know
what it is
maybe because i grew up watching the
three stooges i don't know why but
watching uh
watching people [ __ ] up makes me smile
what is wrong with me
i really am destined to be alone um all
right
speaking of christmas um last week i
made the mistake of i told you i i
bought a different kind of christmas
tree
for the holiday season whoopty doopy doo
um i don't know the past couple years
just to just do you know
for new listeners this week you know i
don't know what happened i just i
last couple years i went there and i
looked at these christmas trees and they
were like
they were like symmetrical and they
would be like you know
six inches of tree trunk and then they'd
have like these perfectly level branches
i just thought they looked badass like
that japanese garden sort of zen looking
[ __ ] and i loved it
and i thought that you know i thought
you know i knew i was gonna get [ __ ]
but i thought at least a couple of
people would come out of the woodwork
and dare to break [ __ ] tradition
let's read some of these
uh these uplifting um comments here
uh bill this guy tried to write damn and
he spelled damn yum
d-a-m-y-u-m damn yum
bill that is charlie brown's tree looks
more like an
anorexic lohan than throne
all right nice tree dick you see this is
what it's like you guys want to get into
entertainment this is what you get all
week this is pretty much the tone
every once in a while hey great special
i loved it but other than that
that tree makes the peanuts crew look
like ballers
i would rather decorate my coat wreck
than that skank shrub
jesus christ somebody wrote this is the
soundtrack to that tree
i i don't get internet in this [ __ ]
room for some reason so i can't click on
that
uh looks like a used up toilet brush
uh looks like the tree the uh tree the
three stooges would have
throw another picture up when you throw
the lights on it
oh look at that and i like that one
that's a twofer
made fun of the [ __ ] tree and made
fun of my bare walls
um yeah people you got a glimpse of how
i lived my life
this is why i'm debt free how you
enjoying your credit card debt you [ __ ]
i know how to live
i buy a christmas tree i can actually
afford
all right uh yeah you probably should
have got the other tree what are you a
[ __ ]
i like it i wanted a charlie brown tree
i was gonna buy a real tree
and cut off half the branches so it was
like charlie brown tree and my girl went
out and bought one herself
so she could say it's hers and i can't
cut it up
okay so that guy was kind of kind of on
my side so what is that
20 against one for me looks like a cell
phone tower in disguise
jesus i'm getting killed here all right
uh let me see something everybody's just
going charlie brown on me here what do
we got
dude i was genuinely excited to see your
tree
where did you pick it out where'd you
pick it out champ [ __ ] afghanistan
it actually looks like something that
would grow out of the soil in hiroshima
no seriously i'm glad glad you're going
out of the ordinary with the tree this
year good good for you
but i had no idea trees could get
hepatitis
merry christmas oh look who's here nia
everybody is agreeing with you you want
to come on the podcast
wait a second let me uh let me get your
mic up here
here you go hi hang on hang on hang on
let me make sure you read go ahead
start talking merry christmas everybody
there you go talk a little more
all right happy holidays all right um
would you like to hear some of these
comments they all agree with you about
the tree
about the tree of the holiday season oh
boy
uh maybe i should have known what to
expect when you describe the tree but i
didn't expect that no offense
but that just looks awful man i have to
admit that that one hurts more than
people who
somebody said look like a cell phone
tower right like those ones are actually
funny this guy
that was that one came from the heart
that really was uh
well i'm a [ __ ] termite and even i
wouldn't take a [ __ ] on that [ __ ] up
tree
jesus wow
sweet tree not oh that's lame
yeah i know you know what that is that's
like from a [ __ ] anthrax fan who's
like
[ __ ] 48 now and has three kids that's
from like uh wayne's world
didn't they always used to say that not
the first time i saw
not was anthrax that guy had it shaved
into his chest
the word not not yeah the guy who then
eventually shaved his head you know
those guys who go bald are always like
hairy like apes
the guy uh the guy who was on that that
vh1 show where they had the super group
oh uh yeah anthony he had the long beard
yeah the long beard shaved head but just
the line the long beard yeah i know who
you're talking about i forget what his
name is remember that
when i shave my head because i'm losing
my hair and you like me maybe you should
[ __ ] uh grow i love you
you love the shade i love when you have
the shaved head i say bring it back
well i think nature is going to bring it
back for me
but well it's good to know that you
still look good well you know i can't do
that [ __ ] rogaine propecia [ __ ] i
just can't i i just know
i know how it works in life you don't
get your cake and eat it
nature's going to get you oh you want to
keep your [ __ ] hair okay why don't we
just [ __ ] take a shot to your goddamn
liver
those people aren't going to lose their
livers you know they're full heads of
hair
what did i walk into i thought we were
talking about the tree
the anorexic tree yes so have you done
any christmas shopping let's do a quick
little interview get uh get the people
all
caught up with you have you uh
look at that tree i think that tree
looks [ __ ] cool as hell it's not the
charlie brown tree
you have to [ __ ] [ __ ] wait a
minute you have to symmetrical the
charlie brown tree was all brown
bill you have to take a picture of the
tree now that it's decorated though
what because i think there's a say it
looks like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] broadway singer with aids
because it's all glitter and skin
bill what a lot of them died of that
oh they do they do dress flashy
you need to stop well i'm not saying
that i agree with that i'm saying that
that's what they would write i like how
that's your out for everything offensive
they i'm not saying i agree with it
it's just how it is there's such a
[ __ ]
dirt bag oh
i saw that movie in the band played on
right that's nice i don't remember
i don't have any guys i don't mind any
guys driving garbage trucks
holding their other garbage truck
boyfriend rocking them slowly
it's not only gay people who catch me i
know it's
that in truck drivers let's not know
what it was just let's move on it's
christmas
huh i know it is no let's talk about
aids and let's talk about oh let's not
play now come on this is [ __ ]
hilarious please stop right now i never
saw it
it was a long time ago i know how did
the song go
i don't know there was a song yeah i
thought in the bed
that didn't happen weren't you asking me
about christmas shopping wasn't it about
san francisco isn't that where they
basically i
don't know and harvey milk came in and
then that other guy shot him in the head
or
that was milk that was milk
oh you want a sean penn can i show you
the most i can't even i i won't even
show this to you because i love you too
much
somebody sent me a youtube video you
guys have to when has that ever stopped
you
huh showing me a horrific channel this
is why this is why you don't get
affection i try to be
i try to give it to you and you slap it
down look at that
what what do you mean what do i got to
replay what just happened there
i said i'd love to show this to you and
but it hurts you
uh you know i love you too whatever the
[ __ ] nice thing i just said
i don't even remember and it was two
seconds ago but i meant it
all right there's a movie called feast
this is going to be on the mm podcast
will you guys
feel free to go on there and trash my
[ __ ] christmas tree i like it
i'm sticking but you know what this is
like this is like the new kid
who comes to school and you guys all
pick on him and i befriend him cause i'm
stronger i can step outside the group
look at me
i'm the hero
it's just a tree i'll [ __ ] you all right
there's a movie
there's a movie called uh feast yep
have you ever heard of that movie okay i
don't know what's going on
i can't i don't want to oh that's my
phone what does your cell phone sound
like the tornado drill from the 50s
because you notice there's no there's no
good ringtones
you know what go go get the uh you know
what i'll let my podcast listeners
decide the ringtone go grab my phone if
you don't mind
all right all right now i'm going to
describe this [ __ ] thing while you're
out okay
there's this this is movie out there
feast that i i have to rent
i don't know what's going on but there
is a woman tied down
and this beast that looks like a little
person
that was uh skinned alive basically
comes out of nowhere
and [ __ ] this woman in the mouth and
finishes there i said it
i said it and it happened so fast i
didn't even think
that it was real and uh
i don't know that's what i have to ask
it's like you're not really trying to
scare me you're just trying to either
gross me out or make me [ __ ] laugh
but if you really want to get grossed
out um
here's another youtube video of the week
somebody sent one in
i only got like two minutes into this
thing and i had to shut it off
human cryogenics
all right so if you guys you know isn't
that funny i told her to go pick up my
phone she goes and answers it and i was
talking to the person
you know what would you broads be doing
if you weren't running your [ __ ] yaps
you know it's like i don't understand
they just they just have to be talking
nia
all right whatever so human cryogenics
red sox fans we're all familiar with
that
you know what i mean ted williams head
i believe is upside down sitting on a
tuna can and they accidentally broke his
nose
i'm talking about ted williams they
froze do you believe in uh
pick up the microphone oh god you're
gonna be eating on the podcast
you know i think this is good that
you're on the podcast it's it's you know
it's the holidays it should be family
some people don't like it though
some people some people don't like my
christmas tree
first of all the internet is like uh
you know like when you hang up those
lights to attract bugs
you can zap them that's what the
internet is for [ __ ] you know what i
mean
i like that analogy yeah they just
gravitate towards
all these miserable [ __ ] who have all
the power in the world to change their
life
and live the wonderful life that we're
living on this [ __ ] bed without a
headboard
i've been trying you know somebody
trashed just because we don't have we
don't have any pictures on the wall
i'm trying to teach people how to live a
minimalist debt-free life
first of all we don't need pictures on
the wall we have
a picture on the wall that bill hates we
have a lot of
pictures this is getting way too [ __ ]
intimate but wait a minute
but we have a picture above the [ __ ]
bed of
it looks like i thought you've talked
about this but have i talked about it
all right well i already brought it up
yeah yeah there's like
every time i look up there's another
deer you can't see it
and it's staring right into the [ __ ]
lens yeah it's not
black and white it's not in color it's
sort of in that blair witch look
it's kind of a sepia tone i [ __ ] hate
it and you know something
i know you hate it yeah and i whoa i
almost fell in between see we need a
headboard i almost just fell off the
back of the bed but i'd like to point
out
i'd like to point out the fact that you
went out and just bought that [ __ ]
photo
yep i did and hung it right look at that
and you just hung it right over the bed
yeah how come he didn't ask me about it
i don't know i just thought it would be
nice really what if i get a poster of
[ __ ] larry bird
he played for the celtics i know
hilarious and he used to do this thing
where he would always wipe the sweat off
the side of his feet so i'm going to get
that so it looks like one of his [ __ ]
blonde balls is going to fall out oh my
short shorts
and i'm going to hang that over the bed
and i'm going to see how [ __ ] long
that lasts
um i just want to say that we have a
mantle and there's pictures all over the
mantel
of all of our friends you know something
that those are the pictures we have all
right you know what this is
this is hilarious how innocent you are
with the internet
what do you mean you don't defend your
position
you know because all you do doing now is
prolonging the argument so now they'll
do
like really do why don't you put a
picture up of them if you have them
because they just want more material to
trash you but they haven't even seen our
apartment who are they to say anything
exactly i'm not i'm just saying what
you're doing is
it's like when someone trashes you how
[ __ ] white your legs are
i know it's great i just take them out
in a job interview and i get it
that's all you do you just agree
absolutely whatever yeah i'm horrible i
look like a puppet
absolutely you're 100 and it kills it
that's what madonna's done
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] i know you want
to see my [ __ ] check out my new book
i got it all over there i got a close-up
didn't she take in
in that book she took a close-up of her
[ __ ] hoo-ha
i don't think so yeah she did you i
think she was fully
nude but there wasn't a close-up that
wasn't that book no
the sex book what book was that i don't
know i don't think it was a little red
wagon
what was the last book that i read
actually that that book was uh my
i think was my favorite work by madonna
and i thought it was their most honest
work
you know standing out there on the
street looking like a [ __ ] prostitute
exactly exactly she looked good
she looked phenomenal she looked really
good i still banged that [ __ ] cougar
yeah you know what i hate you know what
i love is that she's gotten all her
varicose veins [ __ ]
no no this is what i this is why i was
just gonna talk about that because she's
everyone always talks about her arms are
so veiny it's so gross but you know what
madonna works out every day and that's
blood pumping through those veins you
can see
life that's what those veins are oh it's
very inspirational
yeah i mean i know it doesn't look
aesthetically no you know she's like
she's like somebody
who who that's somebody alive you know
she's no you know what she's like she's
like clint eastwood in that movie grant
torino torino yeah i never named that
card the grant that grant trump
do your your impression of that i forget
it
i'll get off of my lawn is that what it
was i can't remember something like that
yeah but then i would say all races ship
which people won't get that i'm making
fun of the movie they'll think i believe
it
well that's what yeah that's what he did
in the movie he was racist
and then he came around but anyway oh
yeah because it's a hollywood movie
well cause it's a holiday movie listen
yes gran torino mm-hmm that that's
that's how she's treating like the way
he treated that car that's why she's
treating her body her body is like in
[ __ ] mint condition
it is you know and all the rest of us
what do we do we [ __ ] back into a car
i don't worry about it slam into a tree
that's how we treat our bodies madonna
doesn't settle for seconds yeah
she's out there waxing it yeah she's
changing the [ __ ] oil
balls to the wall not look at you
this is the whole [ __ ] old school
[ __ ]
this week so uh yes i did go christmas
shopping to answer you
did go christmas shopping i have a
little bit more what did you get me
i'm not telling you it's a surprise
you'll find out on this
shirt you know what sucks about being a
guy is the last time you get a good gift
is i think when you're 11. the second
you turn 12 you start becoming an adult
maybe you get some like electronic [ __ ]
you know you just go into that that
phase where you get shirts
and uh uh organizers
this is a place to put your wallet your
keys
i actually [ __ ] love that you know
that's really unnecessary
[Laughter]
here's the perfect push-ups merry
christmas
i'm [ __ ] with you got me great gifts
you have
first year i was with you you got me the
drumsticks with my my initials
engraved in them that was [ __ ]
adorable what was that those were great
that was cute that was adorable this was
when obviously bill and i were first
all right what are we doing here too
much of our life let's get back to the
podcast here
that was when we were talking about our
social security numbers that are
seven nine eight four oh i was just
gonna say that was what i
thought you brought it up
i'm trying to get you to stop talking
about it fine
all right let me see if i got a question
here that you can actually answer
uh or you can add to i don't think i
have anything you know what this [ __ ]
podcast
oh [ __ ] did i shut it off i didn't did i
please tell me i didn't all right we're
up to 42 minutes
um so
listen yes i uh i got an offer for a
corporate gig
on the day after christmas
and uh eagle rock
and i was wondering if i can go do it no
please first of all that's a [ __ ] lie
all right
second of all no i'm just [ __ ] with
you you always get mad at me when i do
[ __ ] work
the kid you know what this this whole
[ __ ] podcast just i just forgot i was
even doing the podcast and i'm just
sitting here watching you eat oatmeal
all right do you have any closing
comments i got to bring this home with
something funny here do you got anything
anything you want to say oh let's talk
about how i hurt my foot making fun of
your [ __ ] ex i mean oh yeah i made
fun of her exercise tape
she's in there like grunting and
groaning
doing this [ __ ] exercise tape and i
walk in there and it's that dude bob
from the biggest loser
with his shredded head
he like has like he's he works out too
much like he actually
you know the cuts people want when they
get abs he has them on either side of
his forehead
his head is shredded he's in great shape
and those dvds are no [ __ ] yeah so
she sits there and she starts telling me
how
his dvds are hard and all that i was
like [ __ ] that guy i can do that
goddamn dvd i'll be fine typical man
right
and then what happens i go to stretch
before i do it because i'm 42 years old
and you're like
oh you don't need to stretch he has this
whole stretching thing and he [ __ ]
didn't
and i ended up screwing up my foot again
they're stretching in the beginning
yeah that's [ __ ] he didn't he didn't
do any stretches for your back
nothing nothing to stretch out your feet
and then the guy has a [ __ ] [ __ ]
jumper i got bill walton feet at this
point i can't do that goddamn who is
bill walton bill walton was a big
[ __ ] redhead who smoked weed in
college
and hung around john wooden and then all
he does is try to like
john wooden was was this amazing coach
who gave you all this life advice
and he's trying to be john wooden jr
always giving out advice
always telling those stories and he has
this awful [ __ ] voice
that's like it comes from the center of
his head and goes out his
[ __ ] broken nose i remember
i didn't want to get a haircut and he
said you don't need to get a haircut
oh yeah [ __ ] redheaded frankenstein
well in the midst of that workout when
there was all that stuff going on with
the back i was like
why don't you stop and just kind of do
an alternate version of it and you
wouldn't do it because you're a typical
man
and you have to be like i can do
anything you know what i just love that
you're saying
typical man yeah even if they didn't and
then give me [ __ ] when i talk about all
the broads
you've always done that i always have
done that and i i don't have a problem
with you saying that guys are
hard-headed because we are we're [ __ ]
morons
and you guys are psychos you guys are
psychos
all right we're emotional that doesn't
mean i don't like you as [ __ ] bandana
what do you think about that
oh t-bars right from that [ __ ] what's
the name of that group
i was gonna say how long is it gonna
take you to get the name of it
bill never remembers the name crazy sexy
cool was the name of their album
don't go chase i thought they were
saying don't go
jason waterfalls
and i didn't know what that meant i was
like is that some sort of hip-hop slang
who's jason is that like uh
and why does he like waterfalls why does
he like waterfall can you [ __ ] get
the oatmeal you just spit out of your
mouth
oops um
no what was the name of that tlc there
you go
and uh oh left eye because i is right
oh [ __ ] what song is that
what is this oh that's why she that's
why she called herself left eye
because what because i is right
at least that's how she explained it i
is oh right what they said why do you
have that
thing under your uh your left eye or she
had something on her [ __ ] face
and she said because i is right and i
was like oh what a [ __ ]
you know right there oh because she's
dead i'm not supposed to say that when
she was alive she probably wasn't
difficult to be in a relationship with
wasn't she the one who burned down that
guy's [ __ ] house yes she did it
didn't go to jail because she has a
vagina
she went to jail are you dying she went
to jail for that yes well how long
i don't know when she wants the internet
and look it up instead of that's one of
those things where you end up being
wrong
well you end up being wrong and you're
proven wrong so you just [ __ ]
gorilla your way through it like you
just said yeah that's what i'm saying
she did go to jail bill look it up i'm
not gonna look at him and then they
forced her ass to go to rehab because
she was an alcoholic on top of it
anyway with the scene why are you saying
it like she's some sort of a victim she
burned down so he please keep the mic in
front of your mouth
i didn't say that she was a victim i did
not say that
yeah you gave her the out because she
was an alcoholic no i didn't yeah you
guys you guys always
have the whole your whole [ __ ] life
you're just giving excuses that's why
you guys that's why you can't do as many
push-ups as a guy
has nothing to do with your mothering
hips it has to do with the fact
that you [ __ ] get the tee off 20
yards in front of me and still get to
get the same [ __ ] score what does a c
stand for in tlc uh
let's i don't know what the tl stands
for
yes you do tender love and care that's
what it stands for they're the names of
the girls in the group
all right there was chili i got chili
there's left eye
and then there's tea boss there you go
yeah i got it there you go go ahead quiz
me on some more pop culture
give me a little pop culture quiz here
i'll [ __ ] i'll bury it go ahead do it
uh can you name all the members of
no you can't go ahead new edition
absolutely
gone bobby brown uh
jerome robinson latrell sprewell
and uh nipsey russell i was oh he was a
manager he was the manager
i wish that was a group no but i i know
here it is
horrible that's my horrible ring oh
give me a [ __ ] break what do you want
to hear my you want to hear my options
give me another group why don't you pick
a white group so i could actually get it
new kids on the block
new kids on the oh they had all those
gay names joey bobby
stevie mikey and pookie
huh can you feel it baby
i can feel it too was marky mark
stealing the lick and the lips thing
from ll cool j marky mark and who else
and the funky bunny i remember those
guys
yeah feel it feel it and check that
good vibration oh horrible music what
was the
spin-off group from new edition uh bell
biv devoe
wow what are the names poison
[Applause]
[Music]
i remember all that [ __ ] go ahead name a
song
uh by bobby brown when he was solo my
prerogative
these are a joke okay let's see i'm
trying to get
i made this money right joey we didn't
look at my [ __ ] shiny shoes what is
sw i want some crack
what does swb stand for sisters with
voices
you are all on your like r and b
nineties well
all right let me ask you something okay
what's the name of the the maniac in ac
dc you can't sit still for two seconds
you
run around the school boy outfit i took
you to see ac dc what's this i know
the great performers of all time he's
like james brown without rhythm
[Laughter]
he never stops moving the hardest white
uh working white boy in show business
i forget okay it's a kind of beef
angus young there you go there you go
see we should be on the [ __ ] ten
thousand dollar pyramid
give me another one all right uh name
the original
lineup of van halen name as many members
as you can
this this is the white house van halen
of new edition
yeah eddie van halen bang david lee roth
good
that's half the group he's got a brother
it's oh um it's one of the names uh gsp
always says
michael van halen nope alex alex
do you have george shapiro do it come on
alex
hey
jonathan jonathan sweep the leg jonathan
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right hang on a second what else do
we got here where the [ __ ]
oh with the ringtones here's the
ringtones for the week
all right i'll give you another quiz uh
oh you'll get that one i can't even
answer that one that's the same name
name the lead singer of duran duran
you'll get that simon lebon
jerk um
all right we didn't get the guy from
anthrax no i wouldn't get that
all right quiz me quiz me on five movies
then i gotta end the podcast
because i have to go do my [ __ ]
christmas shopping
five movies yeah you know what i'm going
to get you this year
what i'm going to get you i'm going to
get you a uh let me think
i'm going to get you some workout
clothes
right uh maybe like a a
a positive cd a positive cd yeah one of
those things i mean put it on and it
sounds like weather
and it helps you sleep better yeah i'm
gonna get you that and then i'm gonna
get you some new uh toenail clippers
stick that right in your stocking how's
that with that romantic
all right go ahead quiz me on some
movies and then i'm out um
names talk into the mic name at least
five actors in the movie casino
actors in the movie casino all right
that should be it should be easy but i'm
not good with names all right robert de
niro joe pesci yep
frank vincent
uh oh sharon stone mm-hmm and [ __ ]
uh the guy went to mit
yeah i know about his personal life he
had a [ __ ] insane mullet
yeah james brolin
you got james right
was that his name james dear vanderbilt
james van der beek what's that
it's a picture i know of what dear in
the
woods james woods oh james woods that's
right i knew him
all right this is just getting boring
neil we're just boring the listeners do
you have anything that you want to say
before i dismiss you happy holidays
everyone there you go
be good to each other okay now get your
oatmeal
and get out get out that's it yeah
everybody the lovely nia coming in on
the podcast
once every [ __ ] six weeks get out of
here
there you go and she's leaving all right
there you go so that's the podcast for
this week people i know it kind of
sucked
i know some of it was kind of nice but
uh that's it oh you know something what
i keep meaning to [ __ ] talk about on
this goddamn podcast
is i started somebody sent me something
uh about the [ __ ]
what the hell did i do to my damn
computer let it go
let go of my [ __ ] cord
are you [ __ ] kidding me get out
hang on a second people the [ __ ] cord
is stuck in there
whatever people keep sending me this
[ __ ] about uh
one person did sent me about the
liverpool soccer club
in the premier league and evidently
these american dudes
bought it and said that they were gonna
buy uh
buy a brand new stadium they were gonna
do all this type of [ __ ] and they didn't
do it somebody sent me this great video
of all these english people from their
hearts telling these american guys to
[ __ ]
sell the goddamn team and to [ __ ] off
and it was awesome
and this is the same team that the
owners of the red sox then went in and
bought and i started looking at the
premier league
and like three or four of the teams are
owned by uh by americans
specifically people from the united
states all right because we're all from
north america over here
uh and i can't believe how [ __ ]
annoying that would be
you know if a bunch of english guys came
over and bought my team and said that
they were gonna do a bunch of stuff and
they [ __ ] it up
i would be beyond pissed um
so i don't know sorry about that england
i don't know why the [ __ ] we did that
it's nice to know we're buying something
consider japan's come over here and they
they [ __ ] bought up everything over
the last 20 years didn't they don't they
own our roads
you know what are you going to do with
them close them off do you have enough
people to do that i don't think you do
um so yes send me some more information
on that because i'd like to talk about
the premier league and also i'm
wondering in ireland is that a
seven nation rugby league or whatever
the [ __ ] it is is that starting up again
because i watched that last year in
march when i went over there
and uh rugby is the [ __ ]
and uh unlike professional football
which they're just turning into the
biggest [ __ ] sport
ever isn't it enough that we wear that
they have to wear pink
for the entire [ __ ] month of october
you know now you can't tackle people
the amount of quarterbacks out there
that are getting like joe montana
[ __ ] stats because their drive was
kept alive because
a defensive person had the the audacity
to tackle someone is it's just [ __ ]
beyond me
and uh i got nothing left people i'm not
gonna lie to you this podcast was
[ __ ] over before it started i have
too much [ __ ] i have to do
all right i remember the first year i
did this podcast i actually took uh two
weeks off
i took two weeks off so you know
whatever it was dressed down [ __ ]
monday
i came in i i did what i could
all right that's it that's it for the uh
for the podcast for this year everybody
right now we got one more for this year
in next weeks i promise you you
i promise you would be just as bad as
this one if not [ __ ] worse cause i'm
on vacation
i'm not required to make you laugh but i
want to thank everybody seriously
everybody who came out to see um
my shows this year um
i had a great time and i actually oh
wait you know i know what i'm doing i'm
missing underrated overrated how the
[ __ ] could i do that
underrated overrated this week real
quick uh
uh overrated both the jets and the
patriots being a dolphin fan
born and raised in miami i'm sick and
tired of these two [ __ ] teams
dominating the afc east
for the past decade well it's really
been the patriots it was very nice of
you to throw the jets in there i think
the jets have won like what one division
in the last [ __ ] 10 years um so i get
it we're overrated because your team
sucks um hey did you like how the former
dolphin won the game for the jets
yesterday hope that you enjoyed that huh
hope you get a sunburn on your ass you
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right
underrated the bills being a dolphin fan
born and raised in miami
like you already said i love the bills
for always keeping the dolphins in the
hunt
for the playoffs every year for the past
decade and a half
all right that guy was just being a dick
so i have to respect that all right
underrated michael vick
he does sports announcer voice uh
michael vick michael vick
what are one of the things you have to
understand about michael vick is michael
vick the mvp of this season bob because
he's my mvp
he's making fun of me talking about how
that's all they say michael
what can you say about michael vick well
well jim michael vick
um you know what i have to admit i was
[ __ ] wrong about that guy
i was wrong but i was also right okay
because the same reason i [ __ ] fell
for it by the patriots playing good
defense for two weeks in a row and then
actually gave up 14 and a half points
ignoring the fact that they only played
well for two [ __ ] weeks in a row
you can't say that a guy's the best dude
to [ __ ] lead because he lights up the
redskins
and [ __ ] three weeks later john
kitner lights up the [ __ ] redskins
all right but yesterday what happened in
that game i mean that was unreal i think
he went back to old school michael vick
he just started [ __ ] running down the
field like a goddamn water bug but uh
i was wrong about that guy um
it's weird it's but he can't say
he's he's in like a league of his own as
far as like what the [ __ ] he's doing
because i've never seen anybody do that
[ __ ] at his position
and i'd say that he's gonna change the
position
but i don't know that there'll anybody
ever be another person as talented as
that [ __ ] guy at that position
um i don't know so anyways he says uh
bill sorry you have to go through
another week of that [ __ ] of everybody
saying michael vick but every time i
hear them talk about vic
after a big win no matter no matter what
i remember about your rant against the
announcers
about the announcer saying his name over
and over again
i say he's still underrated because he
broke two nfl records in the last two
weeks
but still can't get any solid respect uh
dude i think he's getting his solid
respect
the fact that they're they're saying
that he might be the mvp of the league
and he's coming off an 18-month stint in
leavenworth
for torturing dogs to death you know
what i mean
i definitely when someone plays the
[ __ ] race card i always listen to it
because i you know i travel the road and
i know what people are like
having talked to them there's just
people are [ __ ]
they're awful they're [ __ ] awful but
this is the one time where it's like
dude you know
you tortured dogs to death you drowned
them you shot them i mean straight up
straight across the [ __ ] board you
know you can't expect people to 100
embrace you after you do some [ __ ] like
that even though you more than paid the
[ __ ] price
but i'd rather be you than one of those
[ __ ] dogs
so anyways he said i i say underrated
because he broke two nfl records
in the last two weeks but still can't
get any solid respect honestly as much
as i
uh hate tom brady he is the real mvp so
far
but people are still hesitant i don't
know who the real mvp is but tom brady's
having his best [ __ ] year
um all right
this is a good one here uconn women's
team 88 win streak
overrated the audacity of these media
pricks to compare the yukon's woman's
team
to the ucla team by the way which was
cheating
by the way with how they got all their
prospects for all you people
who trash the patriots and act like all
your [ __ ] winning
is because you're just such smart
[ __ ] human beings it
i'm not gonna get involved and i'm not
gonna open that [ __ ] can of worms but
john wooden
uh as my buddy said yesterday was the
king of looking the other way
when the boosters got involved okay
let's leave it at that all right of
course
it's a major accomplishment but as is
typical with everything male verse
female related people cannot put things
into perspective
when it comes to females the woman's
yukon teams
88 wins is in no way shape or form as
impressive
as the ucla team's 88 wins wins
i'll put it to you like this i used to
play
little league football and got mvp three
times in a row
and co-mvp once however tom brady has
won the nfl
mvp i think once or twice i have
a longer mvp streak than tom brady but
whose mvps
are more respectable and impressive
that's right
mine just kidding of course his are um
all right i i get that
but
uh dude but you're a guy
and you could play in the nfl but you
weren't good enough
so that's the difference i guess
um as far as that i would say that
they're the ucla
the ucla of women's basketball how about
that you got to say that
because they are going up against the
best females out there
and they have won 88 in a row so i would
say it like that but to compet to put it
up there
with uclas yeah the men's i definitely
think that's [ __ ] that's just the
classic
uh you know it's like them wearing pink
in the nfl it's just you're just
appeasing them that's all the [ __ ]
you're doing
you know did i really just compare
breast cancers to like appeasing
somebody i i really should just stop
talking but i'm just going to keep going
here
um yeah as far as sports accomplishments
go i don't think females mean
as much as men's just because we're
better at it than you are
you know and we just have better
hand-eye coordination
just generally speaking we're just
better at you know the amount of guys
that if you go hey think quick
catch and you just throw them a stapler
they're going to catch it in the amount
of women who would just take it off the
face and have it land in their cleavage
is it's you can't even compare it you
know
let's debate that next week i don't
think females are as good athletes as
guys are i just don't i don't think they
are
i don't think that they have that killer
instinct you know
unless they're they're they're
chemically wired like a guy
and they have as much testosterone i
don't think it's going to be a problem
i'm just saying this to piss people off
so i don't have to work hard next week
uh i think that's it i do i got some uh
youtube videos
you know if ever i was gonna edit a
[ __ ] podcast it should be [ __ ]
this one this one is just
jesus whatever last week's was great
this is what you i am you know
this is a letdown week for me all right
youtube check this one out this is one
of the creepiest ones i've seen
and uh it's called the liar card
this is a card you can put in your phone
and
for people you know so when you're
you're if people are ducking your calls
it will show up as somebody else's phone
call
you can disguise your voice to sound
like a woman or a man
and uh i guess you can find out where
they are in case you know
i don't know what there's another good
one uh danny woodhead
you know the [ __ ] all-pro for the
[ __ ] new england patriots
danny woodhead as modell's employee
selling his own reebok jersey he stands
in a modell selling his own jersey
in new england and nobody recognizes him
um another youtube
these all be up on the mm podcast uh the
cliff lee signing did not make the boss
happy
this is actually a total rip-off video
of uh
a video that a canadian's fan made
um or someone who hated the canadians a
year ago uh they just took this footage
of somebody playing hitler in a movie
flipping out
um just know that it is a rip-off but
it's funny i guess
uh what else do i have here i think
that's it is that it
that is it all right all those videos
will be up there i apologize for the
choppy podcast they can all be great
hour and five minutes and by the way
there's some maniac out there
transcribing my podcast
and mark maron's and i think adam
corollas
and uh how about a round of applause for
that [ __ ] trooper i actually sat down
and was reading
i read like three minutes of my podcast
the guy gets like every [ __ ] word
so uh god bless you and uh that is it
that's the podcast for this week you
guys all have a merry christmas
happy kwanzaa happy hanukkah
happy [ __ ] the holidays if that's how
you are i hope you guys all have a good
week don't take any [ __ ] that's it go
[ __ ] yourselves
[Music]
so
you